you can't
be caught up in the [__] that you can't
control i'm in my car and if i'm in my
car i'm in my lane i can't be driving my
car and looking in the lane
next to me because what i'm going to
crash that's some real [__] your car's
moving though right 100
it may not be going as fast as
this one or that one but it's moving and
in life we always in the middle and what
i mean by that is this there's always
people that's doing
better than you and always people that
you're doing better than all six always
it's like you're always a man no matter
what no matter what yeah you got a
hundred million somebody with
with 200 million you understand yeah you
got 300 million and somebody with a
billion so i mean what's up